we must Chris very quickly mentioned
Thor mostly so we can show this picture
sure why would you be embarrassed
a lot of dieting but also apparently is
this true the people this is odd so
people come up to you and they want you
to tell a specific joke well they'll
just come and tell me for a joke like
yeah go you know the joke about the Thor
spends a night with this woman and the
next morning he says I have to tell you
who I am you know I'm Thor she says
you're four I can hardly walk
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you have threatened to recreate your
beautiful Golden Globes moment which you
must be so regretting as you've done
everywhere you go I'm sure you guys saw
this no Brian but we talked about
because Ryan Gosling was on the show yes
weeks ago Ryan Gosling is getting his
award and that's your rap you're here
somewhere oh there you are
is that you oh yeah well I think here
over there but over here stealing the
thunder is Garfield and run so are you
going to do at the Oscars it was a
ridiculous thing I said to Ryan Reynolds
if you win
kiss kiss me instead of your wife and
that's great and the plan was is that he
would kind of move move towards his wife
and then kind of last minute and then he
didn't win much to our disappointment
said to her I said to her we could still
just do it was game but I love the fact
that it was so deep in the background
they said you kind of have to kind of
look to see if it was actually working
he was unaware of it yeah no I know
you're aware of it in it no
what's at the Wolverine origin movie
that you had to do the running naked
down the corridor
now there was x-men - yeah no actually
no first day of x-men origins RN naked I
seem to don't quite enjoy it really I
remember we had to go down this hallway
and I had to run I was meant to be naked
and and it was very dark and and I went
in and I said I want a closed set for
this and the first idea was laughing
anyway went to the first take and I'm
running there's a very intense scene
where I first realize have an adamantium
skeleton I've been experimenting on
naked there's blood I'm like and as I
run around the corner the first ad had
the entire crew like five dollar nose
and of course the first thing idea was
like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
now Tom Adelson you have fan offered
such specific fan art this is a lot yeah
does it all come for this one scene it
was at the first Thor movie with the
spear right right yeah yes
that's it there's a scene in a 1st Thome
where mice I'm trying to attack Thor
Chris Hemsworth as Thor with the spear
and jump in the air and he duck he
dodges out the way and I bring the spear
down and it wedges itself into the floor
and then I lose the user to spin myself
around and kick him in the chest which
has been interpreted by fans as a
demonstration of my hidden talent at
Paul Dunn there's so much of this but
this is just one example of Loki really
going for it on the pole
is that Japanese seen it yeah that's
coquí's outfit
yeah I've not seen that one oh really
we'll print it out you can take it home
dry bit Amy Adams let's see it with the
girls voice
[Applause]
spit it out
so sorry I left that in from early I
always let travel with food on the go
I'm ready for my smack oh come on
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh you're so
[Applause]
didn't you apologize to the crowd of
Comic Con for Batman or Robin
I always apologize but to say that I
actually thought I destroyed the
franchise until they brought it back you
know they'd somebody else brought it
back years later and changed it but you
know I thought at the time this was
going to be a very good career move it
wasn't you talk about how the suit was
the enemy
well the suits brutal you know at the
time particularly I weighed like I don't
know 60 pounds and it takes you know you
have to there was a director Joel
Schumacher's very funny man very tall
very sort of eccentric and he would
direct with a speaker and a with a
microphone and a speaker usually
directors will come up and say hey yeah
okay oh okay and you'd hear this from
you know the filming boys and I bolted
into this suit I can't move and he would
literally go and he would direct you
like as if you would have some emotional
scene he would go okay people all right
George you know your parents are dad you
have nothing to live for
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're gonna be so good at this you're
gonna be so good at this I'm glad I wore
such tight trousers how do you beat your
chest with these so hang on gorilla is
the art
[Applause]
what did you say chimpanzee Pelican do a
wolf as a chimp
[Applause]
you